- I also hear that you're
now of a very exclusive club.
I wanna get this right.
It's in Hollywood, it's called TCC.
- [Ray] That's right.
- TCCC?
- Mhmm.
- [Kelly] What? What is that?
What do you, what is that?
How do I get in?
- The first two letters are Tom Cruise.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Um, and the other
letters are coconut cake.
- [Kelly] Coconut cake.
- Is it coconut or crisp?
- Is it a Christmas cake?
- Oh, Christmas cake.
- TCCC.
- TCCC, yeah.
- Wait, wait.
Did you get a cake too?
- I get a cake.
- You've had a cake?
- You get a cake.
You get a cake.
- [Ray] I got a cake.
You got a cake.
- Work with'em you get a cake.
- I didn't get a cake.
I like cake Tom Cruise.
(laughter)
I like cake.
Is it the most delicious cake ever?
- It is the most delicious cake.
It's, it's up to the standard
of Tom Cruise standards.
It's uh...
- [Kelly] okay.
- It's a coconut cake.
- My mouth is watering.
- It's so good.
I've, I've had it dipped in
resin and I've had it preserved
at my house, cause one day I'll eat it,
but yeah, I've heard it's great.
No, it's amazing.
- It's so good that at our,
at our 25th anniversary...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We had the cake.
We had a, a three tiered TCCCCC cake.
(laughter)
- Oh wow.
- And I ate the second tier all by myself.
- [Kelly] I want this cake.
- Was it, was it delivered
to you in the same way
it was delivered to me?
Because on Christmas Eve
there was just a knock
on my door and I was
really close to the door.
So I was only maybe about
three seconds away from,
I opened it and there was no one there.
And then I looked down and
there was just a pink box.
- Ooh
- [Ray] And it says...
- [Woman] Yep, that's what it looks like.
- [Ray] It says, "Warmest wishes
to you this Holiday Season
Tom Cruise"
- [Kelly] What?
- [Ray] Yeah.
And it was like, it
was as if he dropped by
like on a jet pack and just flew away.
- You know what, it's
Tom Cruise, maybe he did.
- Yeah. I mean, I, I'd believe it.
- I feel like he'd try it.
I feel like he'd be like, I'll try it
Let's do it, yeah.
I feel like he's that guy right?
Mission Impossible.
- [Ray] That's right.
- He'd try any of those things.
- I actually wanna try a
jet pack and eat the cake.
Whatever, Tom.